- Hi everyone, this is Jeremy
Schifeling at Khan Academy.
Thanks so much for joining us
this afternoon, or this evening.
We're thrilled to have
you online with Erin Hill,
an awesome social studies
educator, AP expert,
and general Khan Academy guru.
As you probably know at
this point Erin is one
of our Khan Academy ambassadors,
which means she's used
Khan Academy even before
this crisis started for years and years.
So she knows the product inside and out.
And she can give you particular expertise
about how Khan is used in
the social studies setting.
As you probably also recall
if you joined other webinars
we want to make these sessions
as interactive as possible,
so if you've got questions for Erin
about anything that pertains
to the site, or even beyond,
you can ask those via
the questions feature
right in the GoToWebinar control panel.
So that being said, before
we get to the questions,
I'd love to get to know you better, Erin.
So tell us a little bit about
your own educational journey,
and what's brought you to this moment.
- My educational journey started with
a background in history.
My degree is is history,
and I have a credential
in social science.
And I was fortunate to
start teaching 24 years ago
specifically in middle
school where I taught
both English and history.
So I was able to find
the constant crossovers
between the two subjects.
And I came to Long Beach 20 years ago.
I was very happy to
come down to Long Beach
and teach both English and social studies.
And again, very fortunate
to where I taught
both AP English language
and AP US history.
So I saw AP from different sides.
But I also taught general history,
general English and also honors history.
So a little bit of background on that,
and then currently I am the AP coordinator
at Millikan High School in Long Beach.
- Very cool.
That's such a perfect background,
because I know there are lots of questions
not just about social studies,
but about AP, and I believe you
also have some SAT experience
- Yes.
- for folks who are curious
on what's happening with that
right now in this moment.
Again, totally, lots of great expertise
on display here, folks.
If you want to talk
social studies, AP, SAT,
you've come to the right place.
- Fortunately, one of the great things
the way I was introduced to
Khan Academy was through SAT.
Because we were told by
our district superintendent
Chris Steinhauser, we
have this new vehicle
that we want teachers to start trying out
in their classroom, it's Khan Academy.
They have this wonderful
relationship with College Board
to help prep for the SAT.
A small group just started running with it
and expanded it from there,
and saw all the wonderful
potential for students
in and out of the classroom.
- That's awesome.
So in addition to sort
of using Khan Academy
as this free SAT tool preparation tool,
what other sort of Khan
Academy pieces of content
or courses that you
either use or recommend
that teachers in your school use?
- Well, the teachers at
our school at Millikan
and throughout Long Beach
have utilized Khan Academy
for various levels of math,
for English, for the different
subjects within science.
We even have some of our
PE teachers using some
of the health links within Khan Academy.
We have our computer courses
utilizing Khan Academy
specifically for some of the coding,
and AP computer science principles.
We have some of our business
teachers utilizing some
of the finance and marketing
connections with Khan Academy.
So across the board is
really how Millikan,
and also Long Beach by extension
is using Khan Academy in the classroom.
- Very cool, I can tell
that Long Beach Unified
is definitely a Khan power user district.
- It very much is.
It was not just because it
came from the top down where
it was introduced to us
by again, Superintendent Steinhauser.
But once the teachers
started trying Khan Academy
and seeing what was available to them,
they started thinking
about the possibilities
of how it could enhance,
not just their lessons,
but also make some deeper connections
for the content with their students.
- Very cool.
And so now, let's sort of
fast forward a little bit
to the current moment
that we find ourselves in.
And imagine you're an
AP US history teacher,
or world history teacher,
you were doing great
getting ready for the big
exam in the spring time,
and then all of a sudden this happens.
- Yeah.
- If you were totally
brand new to Khan Academy,
and just coming to this
webinar for the first time,
what kind of initial steps
would you recommend that
a teacher in those shoes takes
to really get started with this platform,
or potentially use it
to serve their students?
- The first thing that I would recommend
any teacher starting with
is exploring what's
available on Khan Academy.
Just because they might
be teaching AP US history
doesn't mean that the
questions, or the content,
or the documents within the
US history content wouldn't
be beneficial to them,
or different aspects under government.
Because again, there's a lot of crossover
with regard to the content.
Exploring what's available,
what are they already doing
and see what can supplement
what they're already
doing in the classroom.
Because one of the great
things about Khan Academy
in particular, is it's
not replacing the teacher,
it's not replacing the content.
It is again, as I said earlier, enhancing
what's already happening.
It's allowing students
to look at something from
a different perspective,
and already build upon
their prior knowledge,
or connections they have
with a particular subject.
Whether it is colonialism,
or The Great Depression
Or the Guilded Age, there's
different aspects within it,
Whether it's a video,
whether it is a document,
whether it is multiple choice questions.
So they're looking at the
content from different lenses,
and they're able to see
what parts they understand,
and get that reinforcement of,
oh I know exactly what this is saying.
Or look at maybe the
idea of Social Darwinism,
or the Guilded Age which
was a very important area
within US history.
And what are those connections,
not just within that time period,
but also making connections
as the content moves forward
into the different decades?
- Very cool, and so
you've talked about this
sort of holy trinity, so
to speak of the videos,
the articles, the exercises.
If a teacher is starting
to explore them and say,
"Hey this is pretty good content,
"this is pretty well in
line with our standards,"
how would you go about
sort of incorporating that
into your existing practice,
or even your new practice
of doing remote teaching?
- It depends on what the
lesson is going to entail.
If I am going to be looking,
having my students analyze
different perspectives
I might look at the different documents
that are available within a unit.
And I can do a modified,
maybe gallery walk,
or a modified jigsaw where
I can split my students
into smaller groups,
or even assign individuals
certain documents.
And as we go into a
group discussion whether
it is through a webcast or an audio cast,
have the students discuss what they have.
But also have the students
upload the document
to maybe a Google Classroom,
or to the classroom locker,
so that the other students can see
the annotation and the
document at the same time.
And it becomes a larger
learning experience where
the student isn't just learning from me,
they're also learning
from the other students
at the same time.
- I love that, so really
sort of empowering
the students, sort of
direct their own learning,
get their hands dirty with history--
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- Instead of sort of passive recipients.
- Yes, oh one of the
things about Khan Academy
that I've appreciated
the most over the years
is the fact that it does lend itself
so easily to student
engagement and interaction.
And it allows them to see
where they are in the moment,
but also what they can do to move forward,
and to continue to build their knowledge
and understanding of a concept.
- So we can definitely go into more depth
as far as executing how
do you give an assignment,
or how do you give out an
exercise if folks want.
They can definitely let us know through
the questions feature.
But let's actually move
towards the AP content.
So as all the AP teachers out there know,
AP is going to this new
online testing format
for this spring.
- Yes.
- Any recommendations about how
they can think about preparing for that,
whether it involves using
Khan Academy or not?
- I think that because
a lot of the students
and teachers might be
uncertain of exactly what
is gonna be happening moving forward,
even though the College Board has said,
here's what we're gonna be
focusing on for different areas.
For example, in AP US
history, and AP world
and AP Euro, they will be giving
a document based question.
Well, Khan Academy has
a lot of documents that
are embedded into each
of those subject areas,
again whether it's documents themselves,
or multiple choice or
even aspects of the video.
So a teacher can look
at the different units
that the College Board will be covering,
because it's a short time frame
with which they're basing
a document based question.
They can really hone in
on what their students
maybe need a little bit more review on,
and then find those
documents that best fit
a particular era.
Or if I'm looking at
world history I might want
to look at the documents
specifically for civilizations
that do a comparison of civilizations,
or changes over time,
which are common themes within history.
- Wonderful.
And then finally for the
sort of SAT question,
before I move to questions
from the audience.
I know that may be the most
difficult to solve given
that basically it looks like a very sort
of bleak future in the short term
as far as testing dates go.
Any advice that you're giving to teachers,
or to students who are
trying to figure out,
hey how do I get my students prepared
for whatever the future entails?
- Every time that I talk
to a student about the SAT
it's really connecting them,
linking their College Board
and their Khan Academy account.
But not just saying we're
linking them together,
actually going in to their
College Board account
to look at their last score report.
Whether it was from a prior PSAT,
or the first time they took the SAT.
And they can actually look
at question by question
from the PSAT, unfortunately,
they don't do that for the SAT,
'cause it's a more secure document.
But for the PSAT they can
look at the actual questions.
But one of the things that I purposely do
is you can look at the
category of each question.
Whether it is words in context,
or the social studies, or the science
whatever it happens to be.
Then the student
themselves empowering them,
as Khan Academy often does,
empowering the student to look at what
are their own areas of need?
Because even though
Khan Academy gives them
a look at where their
current skills levels are,
having the students look
at their SAT score report
question by question,
looking for patterns.
What are their top three areas of need?
Then they go to their
Khan Academy SAT areas.
Whether it's the reading
or writing, or the math.
And now they have what are
their three areas of need?
Instead of more pass, I mean, you know,
the recommended questions are
wonderful, and I love those.
But giving the students the
chance to really choose,
looking at what their scores are,
and knowing inside themselves
what they really need to focus on.
Then they can go through the SAT practice,
and become really down into the detail
of where their areas of need are.
- Cool, I love that theme of
sort of giving students agency
during this tough time.
Because if ever there was
a moment when we need them
to get involved in their
own learning that was it.
- Absolutely, and one of the things is,
even the students will get
a printed score report,
it doesn't give as much detail
as the online score report.
And that's really where the power comes in
of not just the College Board link,
but also the Khan Academy connection.
- Cool, I think this a perfect moment
to switch over to some
questions from the audience.
Renee is saying, hello from Jamesburg.
Hello Renee, thanks
for joining us today.
- Hello, Jamesburg.
- Let's start with a
great question from Joe.
And this is like a really,
a really juicy question right now.
- Okay.
- Which is how would
you recommend incorporating
project based learning
with what we're talking
about here with Khan Academy?
Is there some kind of
connection you can make,
especially given the sort
of difficult circumstances
we find ourselves in?
- I would, and this is
a great piece of advice
from one of the curriculum
leaders in Long Beach,
Nat who's also very
familiar with Khan Academy
and has worked with it often.
Looking at projects and
this new online learning
as a field trip.
What is this new exploration
that the students
are gonna get from this?
Because you want to give the students
that sense of connectedness,
but also give them that
sense of what is it
that we're gonna explore?
What is that question that
we're gonna be discovering?
What is that essential question?
What is that mystery that
we're going to be solving?
And, if you're looking
at a project depending
kind of on what it is,
you can almost use it as,
within a unit in Khan Academy.
And I'm thinking social
studies in particular.
You can have the students
use the documents, use the
questions, use the video
to create their own lesson.
And it could be like a one-pager
where they have created
what is an overview,
in my mind right now, the Guilded Age?
What is an aspect of the Guilded Age?
Or what is, give me a
one-pager about the muckrakers
during the progressive era.
And what are some of the
images that would best work?
What are some of those quotes?
What are some of those dates and details?
If I were to use this as a
study guide for other students,
what would that look like?
What, as a teacher can
do, is they can create
a locker within their classrooms
of the different student work.
And now it becomes a
resource not just for them,
but for the other students.
So I was thinking more project
based of individual students
to help other students
prepare for an exam,
or to enrich their learning.
Or, because technology is so advanced,
using may be a Google Doc, or Google Form,
Google Sheet, whatever that happens to be.
And you can have collaboration
within a project,
whether that's slides,
or some other vehicle
to get the ideas across.
So project based learning
I don't think should
be shied away from.
- Yeah.
- I think that, like anything,
it just can't be thrown
at the student, good luck,
we'll see you in a month.
There have to be, it would have
to be broken into smaller pieces.
And in some cases maybe
allowing the students
to decide what that final
product may look like,
but here are their parameters that
the teacher has set for them.
And what aspects of Khan
Academy they would want
to incorporate into it.
- So cool, I was just imagining
like an amazing project
around, you know pick a
era of American history
that's parallel to today.
- Right.
- Whether it's the
Guilded Age, or the Spanish Flu of 1918,
and pull together the similarities
and the dissimilarities.
- Yeah absolutely, the
continuities and changes over time,
which is absolutely key in social studies.
- Yeah, love it okay,
so let's take a step backwards, actually.
Katherine wanted to take you
up on that offer of saying,
"Okay, I am literally just getting started
"with Khan Academy.
(Erin laughs)
"How do I even set up my class?
"Can I link it to Google Classroom?"
What are those steps?
- Yes.
So one of the things that
Khan Academy done for teachers
is there's actually a section,
when you create your Khan Academy account,
is you click on resources.
And it will give you, it's
how do teachers get started
from simply as how do
you create an account,
to how do you set up your class?
What are the courses within that class
that you want to create?
Do you want to connect
it to Google Classroom?
What are the parameters
for setting an assignment?
What are the class or
classes that you want
to give an assignment to?
So, the way the teacher can get started
is honestly watching the short videos
on how to get started.
If you're not quite as
ready to just go click,
what I call click happy,
and just see how things go.
And one of the things that
Khan Academy also does
with many of their videos,
is they also give text instructions.
So it's helping a teacher
however they are comfortable
with setting something up
to set up the classroom
that's gonna best meet their needs.
So for example, some of the teachers
will have multiple courses
underneath one course.
As I said before, AP US history might also
add US Government, AP
government, and also US history
as aspects of their class,
just because they might
want to do smaller,
different assignments of
the different courses.
So I appreciate the fact
that when you're adding
a class and adding courses,
that Khan Academy gives you the list
of different courses available.
And it's not limited to
one area in particular.
That it does allow for whatever
support your students may need
within that particular course,
or if they need foundational support.
It's also there for them too.
And thank you for showing
that on your screen,
inviting to the Google
Classroom which is so effective.
Not just to our prior to
our current situation,
but even more so today,
because that is one of the ways
that so many students are able
to more easily get their information.
And it also houses things in one place,
so you're not having the students go
to five different sites to
find their one assignment.
Once a teacher set up their classroom
and they can give an assignment,
they can set the
parameters of when that is.
And I like the fact that Khan Academy has
set up the student homepage
to be extremely user
friendly and intuitive.
So the students don't
have to constantly search
for what assignment is due.
And thank you for bringing
out the A student page,
so we're looking at that.
So what are the current assignments that
the students need to be thinking about.
But also, if there's students who may
have missed a deadline,
they can click on past and
go to the past assignments.
And I like the fact that it has the status
of that assignment in there.
For multiple choice or
quizzes, things like that
it does give the percentage.
And some teachers do allow their students
to redo or retake quizzes
to reach a certain
percentage, which is nice.
And then on the left hand side of the page
it will have the list of courses,
and all of their classes.
So again, everything's in
one place for the student
and it's extremely user friendly.
- Very cool, and just to
sort of add that final answer
to Katherine's question, Google Classroom
is basically syncing
up your existing roster
with Khan Academy to save you
all the pain and suffering
of finding rosters in a
remote learning environment.
- And it makes it so much easier.
Not just for the teacher,
but also for the student.
Because as hesitant as we are
to use technology as teachers
the students, if they're
not instantly hooked
in to what that technology is they're not
gonna want to use it.
And so having those
resources readily available,
seeing what their classes are,
knowing what active and
past means immediately helps
the students understand how this resource
is going to help them.
- Very cool.
So going back to this
idea of doing comparison
in the social studies context,
we had a really interesting
question from Daryl.
Daryl says, "My class and I are working on
"the second Industrial Revolution.
"Is there some way to allow us
to attach two different readings,
"or videos, or activities,
those students can compare
"those two different topics side-by-side."
For example, US Industrial
Revolution compared
to British Industrial Revolution.
If I want them to think
of two things at once
how do I do that?
- Absolutely, and so under assignments,
this is where it's really great that you
can have more than one course
within your Khan Academy classroom.
So you can look at the
resources in US history,
or AP US history under industrialization,
and then look at world history
under industrialization.
And really pick and
choose which assignments
or which documents within
each of those courses,
so they can be side-by-side.
And in assignments you
would want to make sure
that you kind of have the
same date and parameters,
so that the students
know they're connected,
and within the Google Classroom.
Or, if there's another
platform that you use
to give assignments,
you can be more specific
with the instructions
on how the students are to
connect those specific documents.
- Okay cool, definitely make
multiple assignments at once.
- Yes.
- Get their students
on their way.
Let's see here, so another
really important question
is coming in from Bea Richards.
Bea says, "Can teachers be notified when
"a student completes an assignment?"
'Cause that way, 'cause
we're all busy trying
to scramble and make this all work.
(Erin laughs)
How do we keep track of
what student's are doing?
- Over the years Khan Academy has done
a really great job about asking teachers,
looking at the Khan Academy gradebook.
And how the gradebook can be
formatted to best parallel
what their current gradebook
already looks like.
So they're looking at assignments.
And thank you for bringing that up.
And it tells you what
kind of assignment it is.
Just as the students are
seeing these different symbols
within their Khan Academy,
the teacher is also
seeing the same symbols
in their gradebook.
So there's a similarity,
which makes it much more user
friendly and re-memorable.
Whether it's a document, or
a video or multiple choice.
And then they've color coded it.
So green obviously
you've met the threshold
of the minimum standard of percentage.
Orange we're kind of, we
may have missed a few ideas.
And then red, this is an opportunity that
the student may want to
revisit, or as a teacher,
this is where you would
really want a student,
a chance to create those mini
lessons of reinforcement.
And review a special, if you're noticing
in your class book for
that particular assignment.
There may be several students who may not
have understood a concept
within that in particular.
So as you're looking at
the assignment scores
you can clearly see who has
done it, and who has not.
But then, if you click
into a specific assignment,
so if you can click, perfect.
- I apologize these are math examples,
but you get some idea--
- That's okay,
it's the same idea, so don't
be scared 'cause it's math.
One of the things is
Khan Academy really does
a deep dive into, not
just the overall score
for a student or that class,
but what it was like for
each individual question.
And so it's no longer a guessing game
for the teacher or the student
on what they understood
or what they didn't,
and what needs to be
reviewed or reinforced.
So if I have you know,
five students in my class,
I'm gonna say five students,
because I'm being I'm being
completely unrealistic there.
- Five problems, yeah.
- (laughs) I only have
five students in my world.
And three of them have
missed the same question.
I can see that instantly in Khan Academy.
And that allows me to go
back to that question.
And if I'm doing say a webinar,
and I'm showing my screen in Khan Academy,
I can actually use that question
and project on my screen.
And the class and I can actually go over
that question again.
Not say, "Oh we've all missed this,"
but, "Hey let's take a look at this again.
"What is the question truly asking?
"Okay, now let's look at
the process of elimination.
"Why do we think this would
or would not be the answer?
"Let's talk about that,
let's come to consensus."
And then if I wanted to I can actually
use another question or an assignment,
and I can have the students
do another multiple choice.
Or I can, you know,
project what that answer is
and why that's the correct answer.
So again, using the, I love
the instant data aspect
of Khan Academy, because it
is so powerful for students.
But having the students look at a question
not just one time, but multiple times,
I think also helps reinforce.
And then it also, if you know going back
to the original question,
what if a student
doesn't do an assignment?
If you notice the student
doesn't do the assignment,
but it also happens to be
a question where an area
where a lot of students
need extra support,
that can then bring the student back into
the conversation, not have
them feel completely left out.
Or I didn't do the assignment,
therefore I can't participate.
So finding ways to use the data as a way
to get that interaction with
students and reinforcement.
- I love that, it really
comes back to what you said
at the very beginning.
Khan Academy is not replacing the teacher,
it's a tool to complement
the teacher's strengths
and expertise, and you
apply it judiciously.
One last question, this is a
really important one from Pete.
Pete says, "You know even in this world
"of trying to get everyone online,
"make remote learning
work overnight basically,
"we still need to keep in
mind differentiate education.
"Serving every student where they are.
"How can we do that in
this new digital world
"using a tool like Khan?"
- I'm gonna go back to Khan Academy
and their relationship with
the College Board and SAT.
Where the practice is
based specifically on
the individual student score report.
So that becomes
differentiated right there.
So if I'm a teacher and
I'm having my students,
and by the way, every
subject is an SAT subject.
It's not just strictly
a English or a math,
it is every subject is SAT,
because every subject has reading,
every subject has analysis.
So you can use it in many different ways.
Going on that, I can have a student,
I can have my students go
to a specific practice,
and it's already set up for where they are
in their skill level within the SAT.
And so it's not leaving anybody behind.
It's not assuming that
everybody knows everything,
or everybody is at the same level,
because that's unrealistic
in any classroom.
When I'm looking at the lessons,
one of the things that I can do
is I can look at the lessons and go okay.
I'm gonna have the students maybe do
a little bit of a practice
question beforehand.
Then I can look at the results.
And then I can differentiate
a lesson from there.
Whether it's reinforcement with a video,
whether it's reinforcement
with a document,
because we've done some multiple choice
and here's a document that compliments it.
Or I can look at some of the key questions
that may have been a
little more difficult.
And then I can break it
down a little bit more,
so I am differentiating for students
who may have difficulty understanding what
a question is asking.
Or, having difficulty with a
concept within the question.
So many times I've taken a
multiple choice question,
and I've projected it on
my screen in my classroom.
Or my whiteboard actually,
because it's a little
bit more interactive.
- Or you can take a green screen
(Jeremy drowned out)
- Yeah, I will literally
project it onto my whiteboard.
And we'll start writing all over it.
And I will have the
students working in groups.
And one group will come
up and they'll do that.
But in, you know, because we
have this now distance learning
having the students do
that in their own way.
And there are some platforms
that do allow that.
But if we're on a webcam,
it's a piece paper
and a pen or pencil.
That can be our technology
on how to differentiate.
And one of the things
that a teacher can do
is by the results that students give,
whether it's on the piece of paper,
or the multiple choice or the document,
the teacher can start differentiating
a little bit from there and scaffold some
of the skills that they see need
a little bit more reinforcement
throughout that lesson.
- Very cool, and so just
to sort of illustrate
that point here, if you
realize that someone
is weak in a certain core area,
especially with the AP exam approaching,
you can always assign that
not to the entire class,
but just to the students
- To specific students.
- who need it the most.
- Exactly.
- Okay I know we're a
little bit over time.
So do you want to end
with one final question,
which is just, you know folks didn't
get their answered today,
or your amazing expertise
has opened up new questions they
didn't realize they had before.
Where would you recommend
they go for support
based on your experience
with Khan Academy?
- One of the things that I found
is looking at that resource page.
Because it gives ideas not
just how to set the classroom,
but different ideas on how
to look at Khan Academy
for differentiation, for
whole class practice,
for looking at remediation, and so forth.
That resource page is,
it's really phenomenal
because it does empower the teacher,
which in turn empowers students.
And the big thing with Khan Academy is
if you want to jump right
into it, great, start small.
You don't have to do
everything on Khan Academy
at the same time, because
would be overwhelming (laughs)
and the students, pick one thing.
Start with one thing,
get comfortable with that
and then add one more thing.
Maybe try one thing a week.
This week we're gonna try multiple choice,
let's see how that goes, okay.
So now we've done our
multiple choice, okay,
how can we do some
differentiation with that?
Okay, next week let's take
a look at some documents.
Next week let's take a look at how we
can incorporate a video and start maybe
a Socratic seminar based on
that particular document.
Start small, get comfortable
and build up from there,
and you're gonna find that the more you
get comfortable with it,
the more you get excited
about how to bring in more
aspects of Khan Academy
that you hadn't even thought of before.
- Very cool, it's so parallel
to how our students learn, right?
They have to have that solid foundation
before they can even extend it
into even more incredible applications.
- Right.
- And the same is true
for us as educators.
- Absolutely.
- Cool, well Erin, on behalf
of the entire audience
I want to thank you so much for sharing
your expertise today.
I think you've given us so
many tools and resources
during a very tough time.
And for that we really
appreciate all your generosity.
- Thank you so much for having me,
I really appreciate it.
And, thank you all for
being willing to take
on Khan Academy, because
it is really exciting.
I was fortunate to were I've
seen Khan Academy progress
over the years to helps
students, but also teachers.
And Khan Academy continues
to do that all the time.
They're bringing out new curriculum,
they're bringing out new resources
for teachers and students.
It's a really exciting time to see
what's gonna happen
next with Khan Academy.
- Very cool, well thanks
everyone for joining us,
investing in the session today.
Thank you again, Erin.
- Thank you.
- Wish you all a good evening
or good night.
- Have a good evening.